مزيد من التطورات نتابعها من اوديسا مع
مراسل الجزيره عامر لافي ومعنا ايضا من
دونيت مراسلنا نور الدين الدغيرو بكما
البدايه معك عامر كما كنا نشاهد اذا قصف
فكره من قبل الجانب الروسي وايضا
فيفا غرب اوكرانيا ماذا في تفاصيل هذه
الهجمات الروسيه
نعم سفيان يعني كما ذكرت هجوم واسع في
ليله طويله كانت على اوكرانيا وليست
الليله الاولى يعني
بدات تعتاد على هذا القصف اوكرانيا كل
ليله هي على موعد يبدو على مع قصف مع قصف
يطال العديد من المدن الاوكرانيه هذه
الليله تحدثنا عن 24 صاروخ وفقا لقياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه اسقط منها سته عشر
صاروخا طالت 13 مقاطعه في اوكرانيا اليوم
يوري اجنا المتحدث باسم قوات القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه تحدث عن ان
الاستراتيجيه التي اتبعتها روسيا في هذه
الضربات استخدام صواريخ كروز الجوال
القادره على تغيير مسارها اكثر من مره
لخدع والخداع المضادات الارضيه الاوكرانيه
وهذا ما فعلته هذه الليله قال ايضا بان
ربما
المختلف هذه المره وعدم استخدامها
للمسيرات شاهد ايرانيه الصنع في العاده
تبدا الهجمات الروسيه بهذه المسيرات ثم
انت طلعت تتلوها بعد ذلك الصواريخ لكن
لهذه المره فقط كانت صواريخ وصواريخ
باليستيه معظمها صواريخ من نوع كروز
متعدده الانواع في هذا الاطار ايضا تحدث
مدير مكتب الرئيس اندريه عن ان جزء كبير
من هذه الصواريخ كان من نوع مئه وواحد
وقال بان هذه الصواريخ تحتوي تقريبا على
30 قطعه مستورده من الخارج قال نحن نتابع
ونرسل المعلومات اولا باول الى شركائنا
نعم هناك حصار وهناك تضييق وهناك يعني منع
لوصول هذه المواد
والاجهزه والقطع الى روسيا لكن نريد تعزيز
هذا الحصار تعزيز هذه العقوبات لحرمان
روسيا من صناعه مثل هذه الصواريخ وضرب
المواقع الاوكرانيه المدنيه كما يقول مدير
مكتب الرئيس بالنسبه للخسائر التي وقعت
ربما اكثر الخسائر كانت
بالارواح في مدينه او في مقاطعه فولين
وتحديدا في بلده لوتس في المدينه يوجد
فيها مصنع لقطع غيار السيارات وفقا لعمده
هذه المدينه قصف هذا المكان يقول بانه ليس
له علاقه بالصناعه العسكريه وقتل هناك
ثلاثه اصيب اربعه بالاضافه طبعا الى ليفيف
واكرم تروس تحدثتم عنها قبل قليل قتيلان
وعدد ايضا من الجرحى في قصف مستودع كبير
للمواد الغذائيه ابقى معنا عامر اذهب الى
دونيتسكو ومراسلنا نور الدين الوضع متوتر
حيث انت ايضا هل واضح ما الذي تسعى اليه
موسكو وماذا تريد تحقيقه تحديدا في هذه
المناطق
نعم سفيان يبدو انه بعد الهجمات التي
تعرضت لها روسيا سواء موسكو او الحدود عبر
المسيرات وعبر استهداف جسر شبه جزيره
القرم يبدو ان الرد الروسي جاء سريعا
باستهداف مجموعه من المناطق المناطق تمتد
الى اقصى الغرب في الى والى اقصى الشرق مع
منطقه في مناطق خاركيف وكرامه هذه المناطق
التي تم استهدافها بالصواريخ الحديث
الروسي هنا عن الاستهدافات كان واضحا من
خلال ما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التي
قالت بانها استهدفت بصواريخ وبنظام عسكري
عالي الدقه وبعيد المدى سواء من البحر او
من البر مواقع ترتبط بالصناعات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه بمعنى ان المستهدف الذي قامت
باستهدافه القوات الروسيه هي مواقع عسكريه
مئه بالمئه لكن بكل تاكيد تختلف هذه
المواقع باختلاف المناطق هناك حديث عن
استهداف مستودعات للذخيره وه يتم الحديث
على ان ما تم استهدافه فكره
هي مستودعات وحينما يتم الحديث روسيا عن
المستودعات بمعنى مستودعات الذخائر
العسكريه وخاصه الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه منها
المسيرات التي تهاجم روسيا ما بين الفينه
والاخرى منها الصواريخ التي تسلمتها
اوكرانيا من الدول الغربيه سواء هيمرس او
سترب شادو اذا هذه احدى الاهداف الاهداف
الاخرى التي يتم الحديث عنها هي مراكز
الصناعه العسكريه هاته المراكز تم
استهدافها كذلك بهذه الصواريخ وهي جزء من
استراتيجيه الدفاعيه والهجوميه للقوات
الروسيه لمنع اي تطوير للاسلحه خاصه اذا
ما علمنا ان مجموعه من الصواريخ التي تم
استهدفت من خلالها روسيا هي عباره عن
صواريخ مطوره من اسلحه دفاعيه كمثل الاسم
200 ليصبح سلاحا هجومي وهناك نقطه اساسيه
ومهمه وهي استهداف المطارات كذلك تتحدث
المصادر العسكريه هنا على ان احدى النقاط
التي تم استهدافها خاصه في احدى المناطق
داخل اوكرانيا كانت عباره عن مطار تقلع
منه طائرات الصخور 24 لكن بكل تاكيد كل
هذا ياتي ضمن اطار استراتيجيه عسكريه
روسيه لمنع اي تقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه او
القدوم بالقيام باي خطوه عسكريه من اجل
الحد من النفود العسكري الروسي سواء
باتجاه الشمال والشمال الغربي وسواء
باتجاه الجنوب خاصه ان هناك قراءه زكريا
تتحدث على ان التحرك باتجاه جنوب دونيت
الهدف منه ان تجد اوكرانيا منفذا لها الى
بحر ازوف وربما كان موقف وزير الدفاع
الروسي واضحا من استهداف بعض المواقع
العسكريه خاصه في اوديسا ولنستمع ما قاله
وزير الدفاع الروسي
اظهر نظامك باستخفافا خاصا بتنفيذ مبادره
البحر الاسود للحبوب لقد تم انشاء مخزون
كبير من الاسلحه والذخيره في اوديسا
وموانع اخرى على البحر الاسود وبالقرب من
مخازن الحبوب يتم انتاج الطائرات المسيره
والمسيرات البحريه التي قصفت مرافق البنيه
التحتها في شبه جزيره القرم
اشكر اذا نور الدين الظهير الذي كان معنا
من دونيتسكو وايضا عامر اللافي من اوديسا
شكرا